this is Betty a blue collar worker who
tends the counter at a fast food
restaurant and this is Wilma she's a
white collar worker who writes computer
code both make average salaries for
those two groups from 2010 to 2012 the
salary for Wilma's position would have
grown more than Betty's but from 2020 to
2022 it was Betty that would get the
bigger bump wage gains for some blue
collar workers have started to outpace
gains for white-collar workers over the
last three years A reversal from a
decades-long trend this is a pretty
remarkable moment in history here's why
wages have been growing faster for
low-income workers and why those gains
have helped Stave off a recession
first it's important to understand who
exactly qualifies as blue and white
collar Blue Collar has become more
all-encompassing term for lots of
different wage workers often at the
lower end of the income Spectrum but not
exclusively and white collar tends to be
more salaried professionals uh who are
typically working in office like
settings non-management Blue Collar jobs
tend to include people that work in
restaurants hotels factories retail
stores and construction White Collar
jobs include some but not all office
workers like people in finance Tech and
law the pay gap between some industries
that fall in these groups has steadily
grown you can especially see that divide
between Betty and Wilma
part of the reason that Gap has grown in
the past there has just been so much
demand for skills like Computer
Engineering like software engineering
and not as much Supply and there has
been far more supply of workers prepared
to do low-age work the pandemic also
increased the need for white-collar jobs
which could easily be worked from home
but when the economy began recovering a
different demand arose
to what hurt us the most is uh you know
it's hard to find people to work
people returned to activities far faster
than companies could hire creating
competition for many traditionally low
wage positions and many blue collar
workers didn't return at all we had a
lot of retirees during the pandemic who
have not returned to the labor market
and immigration was depressed as well so
we had fewer people entering the country
to fill especially lower income jobs
many workers were also quitting their
current jobs which could be a sign of
more worker Leverage
when workers are quitting in large
numbers it's because they're easily able
to exchange their jobs for better jobs
and when workers are being laid off in
large numbers it's because employers
hold the upper hand and are easily able
to exchange workers for better workers
workers who did leave for higher paying
jobs also saw higher wage gains than
people who stayed when employers are
short staffed the immediate problem at
hand the fastest way to solve that
problem is to hire someone they're often
prepared to throw huge amounts of money
at hiring a new candidate signing
bonuses you need a new benefit in order
to come out okay sure so as demand went
up and Supply went down for blue collar
workers the opposite happened for
white-collar workers which kept their
wage gains at a lower level than they
typically would be to the extent we have
seen shakiness in the labor market it
has been in some of these white-collar
professions like the tech industry while
some economists consider the slowdown in
White Collar jobs more of a return to
pre-pandemic levels the Boost in Blue
Collar pay is keeping spending elevated
even during inflation
hourly earnings surpassed inflation for
the first time in two years in July
largely driven by gains for low-wage
workers we have actually seen some parts
of the economy receive real wage
increases that have expanded their
purchasing power and allowed them to buy
more to move into Better Homes to invest
in in better schooling for their kids
and and to improve their life conditions
some economists say that this increased
spending power for lower income workers
and the tight labor market have been
major factors in avoiding a recession so
typically intercessions lower income
workers by virtue of the jobs that they
work in or the tenure that they have at
those jobs tend to be some of the first
to uh be let go or to not be hired in
the first place if those workers are
making more money and they're remaining
employed they are propelling economic
growth forward and they are keeping
other people in their jobs and they are
preventing a recession from happening
which creates a virtuous circle for
everyone involved while these earning
boosts have helped close the gap between
blue and white collar workers somewhat
the amount that Betty our food worker
and Wilma our computer programmer make
today is still very different and as
Federal Reserve officials continue to
tackle inflation they're taking an aim
at cooling the job market what we're
talking about is having wage increases
still at a very strong level but at a
level that's consistent with two percent
inflation over time wages have started
to cool and the trend has reversed in
recent months
some economists are optimistic that the
gains for low-income workers will
continue I don't think we're going to
see these wage gains erode because the
labor market is still tight in those
low-wage Industries but wage canes for
blue collar workers would need to keep
outpacing those for white collar to
continue closing the gap
foreign